China is encircling Taiwan with warships
and jets right now as we speak we're
talking at least nine warships and 71
military aircrafts Jets and helicopters
are circling around warships are sailing
super close to taiwan's Islands with
this one firing off a warning shot
towards one of taiwan's islands and this
is happening days after a meeting in
California between taiwan's President
and the U.S speaker of the house so in
response China launched a three-day
military exercise as a Stern warning to
Taiwan where they practice deploying
their military to the north south and
east of Taiwan for the sake of
patrolling the area convenient right